overall test positivity has drastically
declined good news here when you take a
look over the last month straight down
statewide it is at 11.5 percent joe
muller spoke to one doctor who says the
decline in cases is due to a number of
reasons joe is live at testing and
vaccination site over at unlv this
evening with what that doctor has to say
joe
o'brien this site here is open from
sunday through thursday i'll give you a
live look here at this hour it's usually
a lot busier than this but there are a
steady stream of cars coming through
here people getting tested and
vaccinated well as test positivity
declines medical experts say sites like
this need to continue to operate
i want to make sure i'm ok
people getting tested for cobin 19 say
the first step in stopping the spread is
knowing you have it i don't want to get
anybody else sick and i want to be able
to return back to work the test
positivity rate in the state of nevada
is down from 16.3 percent a month ago to
11.5 percent tuesday i think the number
one reason is because we've started to
implement those public health measures
that were so effective dr christina
madison from roseman university says
more safety measures and more testing is
playing a role in keeping cases down
we're also seeing more people testing
because there are more facilities and
more businesses that are requiring
testing in order for people to come back
to work safely madison says more vaccine
requirements will continue to make a
difference we saw with the
implementation of allegiant stadium
requiring vaccinations you saw you know
eighteen thousand people cancel their
tickets tuesday the state said
transmission is still too high in every
county and masquerading needs to
continue madison hopes we can get back
to the three percent test positivity
rate we saw in june i'm very hopeful
that we will continue to get those rates
down and get back to where we were
now back out here live the unlv stan
fulton site tonight is getting extra
help from state and federally funded
surge teams that were put together with
fema to promote vaccinations here in
southern nevada we've seen those teams
also go door-to-door promoting vaccines
in the past reporting live here at unlv
joe mohler 8 news now